[Music]
uh welcome to the big chill seven
dollars and 23 cents
don't if you tip me i have to sing
really
okay i'm going on a break wait wait wait
it seems like i made you mad that's not
what i want to do cause
baby me and you could go together like a
double scoop fine
you want me home after work perfect it's
a date it's not a date which sure sounds
like a day
so saturday here i'll pick you up at
seven it's a date
okay fine but just once and it's another
day
does this girl have a name isabelle one
more
one more me and my dad we try to
formulate a plan
honor society student council track blah
blah blah is that what you really want
though
come with me whoa that's called my boof
of proof
let me see what you got no i don't rap
dude you're wasting time
see you later on i'm sorry man
look just because i know what i want
doesn't mean i always get it but at
least i'm honest with myself
what do you want i want to take you out
again
people do things when they're dating i'm
not dating darren you're gonna have to
leave
do you even like me it's not that simple
everywhere i look i see you i'm just
chasing after something i have a year to
live if that
life goes on it moves like a
merry-go-hog no it's not always easy
but nothing ever is that's why we make
plans all right
girl let's run away i have a plan izzy
we're going to live our full life all
the milestones all in this year
me and you go away darren i don't
believe in happy endings
believe in me one condition
anything you have to stop saying i love
you want folks to fill your music you
got to throw it first
so what you got for me something but
it's rough that's more than most people
got it
the only way to learn about life is by
living and i've learned
that every moment is your moment
[Music]
if you can manage to look past your own
fears and
everyone else's expectations the reward
is your life
you